a hidden pattern is popping up in
seemingly unrelated places from a bus
system in Mexico to chicken eyes to
number theory and quantum physics this
phenomenon known as universality
continues to surprise mathematicians and
reveal a deeper understanding of our
world imagine arriving at an empty bus
stop in New York City the last bus must
have just left but the sign says a bus
comes every 10 minutes on average what's
the probability that the next bus will
arrive within five minutes the
probability of a random event happening
within some interval like a bus coming
within the next 5 minutes it's given by
a curve called a Poisson distribution
but what if bus arrival times are not
independent in the 1970s in Cuernavaca
Mexico bus drivers would hire spies to
sit along their route and the drivers
either speed up or wait at a stop
depending on how long ago their spies
said the previous bus left
this faced out the buses and maximize
their profits in that case the spacing
between buses is defined by a very
different probability distribution the
Cuernavaca bus system the Riemann zeta
function related to prime numbers
chicken retinas and atomic nuclei are
all examples of complex correlated
systems the components of these systems
aren't independent they interact in
repel one another and this leads to a
statistical distribution in between
randomness and order the same
distribution or pattern arises even
though the components of these various
systems are very different they are said
to exhibit universality mathematicians
model these complex correlated systems
using random matrices the numbers and
random matrices are drawn randomly from
probability distributions the matrix
might be randomly filled with zeros and
ones or with any set of numbers like the
integers between 1 and a hundred you can
characterize a matrix by its eigen
values a series of numbers that can be
calculated by multiplying components of
the matrix together in a certain way I
can value some certain random matrices
are always spaced along the number line
in a characteristic pattern with
consecutive eigen values never too close
together or too far apart the same
pattern of eigen value spacings arises
no matter how you fill the matrix with
random numbers if you plot the distance
between consecutive eigen values on the
x-axis and the probability of getting a
particular spacing on the y-axis the
familiar lopsided curve begins to appear
researchers are still looking for a
general answer to where this universal
pattern comes from but clues continue to
emerge the idea of random matrix
universality goes back to Eugene Wigner
a Nobel prize-winning theoretical
physicist who worked on the Manhattan
Project
Wigner was attempting to calculate the
energy levels of a uranium nucleus which
has more than 200 protons and neutrons
that can arrange themselves in all
different configurations
The Associated energy levels of the
system were far too complex to calculate
Wigner used random matrices instead and
plotted the statistical distribution of
eigenvalues he found that the spacing of
these numbers matched the spacing of
energy levels of uranium and other heavy
atomic nuclei two decades later the
pattern was seen in gaps between
consecutive numbers called the zeros of
the Riemann zeta function these zeroes
are thought to control how prime numbers
are distributed since then the pattern
has been seen in many different settings
like in human bones and social networks
just recently it showed up and yet
another unlikely place the eyes of
chickens it was the first instance of
the pattern seen in biology while the
number line exhibits a pattern of
universality in one dimension the
chicken retina cells reveals it in two
dimensions the color sensitive cone
cells in the chickens retina seem
haphazardly distributed but with a
remarkably uniform density looking
closer the cells appeared to be
surrounded by what's called an exclusion
region a space where cones with
different color sensitivity can be found
the cones of the same kind cannot just
how these cone cells create the
exclusion zones remains a mystery but
it's similar to the repulsion between
consecutive random matrix eigenvalues on
the number line
researchers say we're just at the tip of
the iceberg in understanding
universality in math physics and even
biology
[Music]
you